Evan murakawa cool guy he said open AI
he tweeted something that he also was
really kind to send me uh to communicate
with me send me long email describing
the history of open AI all the different
developments
um he really lays it out I mean that's a
much longer conversation of all the
awesome stuff that happened it's just
amazing but his tweet was uh Dolly July
22 Chad GPT November 22 API 66 cheaper
August 22 embeddings 500 times cheaper
while state-of-the-art December 22. Chad
GPT API also 10 times cheaper while
state of the art March 23 whisper API
March 23 gpt4 today whenever that was
last week
and uh the conclusion is
this team ships we do uh what's the
process of going and then we can extend
that back I mean listen from the 2015
opening AI launch GPT gpt2 GPT 3 open at
5 finals with gaming stuff which is
incredible GPT 3 API released uh Dolly
instruct GPT Tech that I could find
tuning uh there's just a million things
available the dolly dolly 2 preview and
then Dolly is available to 1 million
people whisper a second model release
just across all of the stuff both
research and
um deployment of actual products that
could be in the hands of people uh what
is the process of going from idea to
deployment that allows you to be so
successful at shipping AI based
products
I mean there's a question of should we
be really proud of that or should other
companies be really embarrassed yeah and
we believe in a very high bar for the
people on the team
we
work hard
which you know you're not even like
supposed to say anymore or something
um we give a huge amount of trust and
autonomy and authority to individual
people
and we try to hold each other to very
high standards
and
you know there's a process which we can
talk about but it won't be that
Illuminating
I think it's those other things that
make us able to ship at a high velocity
so gpt4 is a pretty complex system like
you said there's like a million little
hacks you can do to keep improving it uh
there's uh the cleaning up the data set
all that all those are like separate
teams so do you give autonomy is there
just autonomy to these fascinating
different problems if like most people
in the company weren't really excited to
work super hard and collaborate well on
gpt4 and thought other stuff was more
important there'd be very little I or
anybody else could do to make it happen
but
we spend a lot of time figuring out what
to do getting on the same page about why
we're doing something and then how to
divide it up and all coordinate together
so then then you have like a passion for
the for the for the goal here so
everybody's really passionate across the
different teams We Care how do you hire
how do you hire great teams the folks
I've interacted with Open the Eyes some
of the most amazing folks I've ever met
it takes a lot of time like I I spend
I mean I think a lot of people claim to
spend a third of their time hiring I for
real truly do
um I still approve every single hired
open AI
and I think there's
you know we're working on a problem that
is like very cool and the great people
want to work on we have great people and
some people want to be around them but
even with that I think there's just no
shortcut for
putting a ton of effort into this
so even when you have the good the good
people hard work I think so